hi Samuel easy I hope you're well today
I want to talk to you about something a
little bit different from what I
normally talk about you guys will know
me as the property guy and I love
investing in property however I have got
some really good friends that invest in
other things and they're making
ridiculous money and I'm almost a tiny
bit jealous so I wanted to introduce you
to my good friend Marcos de Maria I live
right now how are you and we're here in
London at Marcus's office and you just
got back from Amsterdam all this guy
does attend weddings and events stocks
yes so I've just been showing Samuel my
portfolio which has been going up here
yeah absolutely I'll just go through it
with you we've got a gain here of two
hundred and twenty percent as you can
see four hundred and sixty-five percent
forty six percent eighty percent two
hundred ninety five percent two hundred
and eighty five percent two hundred
eighty nine percent ninety six percent
by the way they're not all winners right
there's gonna be some losers alone but
this one is a good one three thousand
and seven hundred percent by the way too
ridiculous that he is two months and I
think my thing in a moment so I'm gonna
run a fifty six percent thirty four
percent they go there's a loser there I
lost eighty nine showing the thing you
showed me a second ago I don't even know
what the what the one at the top yeah
how much you made in the last yeah so I
put in seventy three grand and I made
sixty seven grand and that was in about
a month and a half it's really important
not what you know but also who you know
so you need to get to know this guy and
I'm so excited about what Marcus has
been sharing with me I thought I'd put
on an event and Marcus is kindly said
he'll come down and basically teach
everything he knows about the stock
market and summarize it all into one day
so if you're interested then what I
would say is get yourself down I'm sure
there'll be a link somewhere on the
bottom of this video so get down cover
meet Marcus in person
and find out a little about the stock
market because I really think it's good
to diversify as much as you can
I'll always love property but Marcus
we've got my spended oh yeah look the
thing is I love property as well I've
got quite a
few of them around to the UK but in
stocks and shares it allows you to make
money going up and down so that's why
over the last 16 years I've been
concentrating on stocks my wife has been
concentrating on property so we do both
yeah excellent
hope to see you there